l'homme de 59 ans avait son bureau ici à
l'inspection académique de haute saône à
vesoul
il s'occupait du sport scolaire pour
tout le département l'urss et c'est en
janvier dernier que l'inspectrice
d'académie a signalé à la justice un
comportement douteux de l'individu suite
à des signalements qui est fait par des
parents d'élèves qui comprenait pas le
comportement paraît série adaptée d'un
enseignant chargé les activités
sportives vis-à-vis de jeunes mineurs
donc nous avons ainsi initié une enquête
préliminaire concernant une dizaine de
plaintes
il était très connu dans le département
très investi dans le sport il avait même
coordonné l'organisation des jeux
internationaux de la jeunesse à vesoul
en 2018
depuis janvier c'est un autre homme que
la justice découvre
nous avons donc entendue
la personne mise en cause au mois de
janvier dans un premier temps avec une
perquisition qui a permis la saisie de
très nombreux matériels informatiques
nous avons ensuite exploiter ce matériel
informatique notamment les clés usb
avons découvert de très nombreux
fichiers à caractère pédo pornographique
qui a conduit à leur placé en garde à
vue à ouvrir une information judiciaire
pour corruption de mineurs agressions
sexuelles l'ancien responsable de l'ue
est nécessaire dans le département est
en détention provisoire à la maison
d'arrêt de besançon
l'enquète quand elle se poursuit a été
confiée à la brigade de recherches de
lure alors cette affaire est un
véritable séisme haïtien en haute saône
les connaissances de l'individu sont
sous le choc elles n'ont pas souhaité
s'exprimer face à notre caméra
il en est de même pour le personnel de
l'inspection d'académie où nous nous
trouvons personne n'a souhaité réagir